welcome to the across the spoiler vers
podcast your boys are back it's Tuesday
we're ready to drop some news talk about
everything we missed last week because
in case you guys didn't see just
everything got brought crumbling down
after last week's episode and we were
sitting like oh if we' only recorded it
the day later we'd have so much more to
talk about but there's lots of things to
go over I'm joined Once More by Greg
Alba from real rejects yeah you've had a
bit of a fun week it went a bit Swift
for you ahe that Greg oh man was it
Swifty for me buddy I had a great time I
even got my bracelets on today buddy I
had a wonderful time I've asked Paul
permission Grant he was granting me
permission I wrote him a letter and
everything allowing me to review the
Taylor Swift concert experience the arys
tour because it was an experience that's
for sure so that's one of the many
things we got to talk about today
because you're right man we had a lot
that came out there'll be video chapters
uh if you guys want to hop around uh
because we got stuff to talk about with
Daredevil oh man that just kept
developing a Marvel box office Aquaman 2
oh boy and uh sag Afra Halloween writes
Willow man there's a there's a whole
bunch to get to my friend but uh you had
a wedding you went to how was it did you
have a good
time I got really drunk too drunk and
fell on the floor when I got in and just
slept there for a bit so that that was
pretty fun I mean we've got another
wedding coming up very soon uh looking
forward to it just Liv living the life
watching people get happy lives
themselves and get to be with the person
they love now it sounded like you know
on the day it sound like it was going to
be a match made in heaven and these
people are going to be together forever
which kind of takes us into our first
section which is talking about what's
going on with marvel at the moment um in
case you guys have missed the headlines
there's been a number of crazy czy
report all hitting the web this week
we've had things like the Marvel's
opening weekend predictions um Joanna
Robinson's just dropped a really
interesting book talking about all the
behind scenes stuff on Marvel and we've
heard lots of things about what's going
on with Daredevil now I'm gonna say I
know I keep talking about how I feel
Marvel's gone off track recently and
stuff I'm really enjoying Loki season
two I've just just the other day
finished watching episode three um I
really enjoyed it you know in case you
guys don't know we we do get sent them
early well the first we're getting some
of them you don't normally tend to get
them the more important episodes given
to you but yeah the first first handful
and I have to say I'm really enjoying it
so far I think it's kind of striking the
right balance with me in terms of what I
want tonally where it takes itself
serious but has jokes in it's not
written to be a comedy and it's got lots
of exciting things that happen in it
like there's a certain thing that uh we
we we found out about months ago um
through a certain post credit scene in
the film and I thought it was going to
go one way and play out like that just
give my predictions on it and watching
the way they did it yeah complete
surprise and it it's nice when you you
feel like you have such an understanding
of the comics and the characters and
they just throw a couple of curve balls
away and keep things moving yeah I agree
I mean I I I just saw episode three
myself and what I like so much about
what this season is there's Everything
feels consistently tethered I would say
yet there each one does feel different
from the other like when you're looking
at the three episodes while the
direction is consistent and while it the
darkness is consistent each one does
feel distinct from one another and it
does go in directions you often wouldn't
expect personally I still episode one is
still my favorite of the three we've
seen so
far and I think when you say that that
just means like oh does that mean you
don't like episode two and three no
that's not it at all uh I really like
episode two I like episode three more
than I like episode two that's for sure
um and I I feel like episode three is
going to be a conversation I I I imagine
there'll be like little things here or
there that people might have some gripes
with because they they definitely get
weird they definitely like weird in a
way that I don't iag like a little
quirky in a way that I don't imagine I
know what you mean yeah you know what
I'm hinting it would be a spoiler even
though it's not like a big deal if I
even said what it is would be a major
spoiler spoiler you did it you did it uh
but no I I think it's still um I wish
apparently it's like the second most
watched thing ever or whatever the
numbers are saying uh but it doesn't
seem to be reflecting I don't know
Disney has a way of spinning numbers
together in creative ways well so yeah
they dropped the the viewing figures
earlier in the week and they talked
about how it was the second highest
viewed premere of the Year sitting
behind the Mandalorian it I think it
came in at about 10 million views okay
but then I'm thinking well a SOA they
said it was 14 or 15 million they did go
back and forth on the numbers with that
so I'm thinking well how how is this the
unless they're counting those two
episodes as like the combined view I'm
guessing they are but yeah so so yeah
but there has been a slight dip um and
obviously there's been a lot of Panic
behind the scenes as we've just found
out a major reshuffle that's happened
with Daredevil born again so The
Hollywood Reporter they dropped an
insane story talking about how much
things have been reworked and what's
basically happened is um the writer
strike obviously stopped everything so
they couldn't really announce it during
that time but when the writers all got
back together apparently everyone
connected to the writing side and I
think it was even the show Runners they
all got brought in to Marvel or that
might not even been brought in just told
told look we're we're restarting again
we're we're everyone's fired we're going
in a different direction we don't feel
like it's working so according to the
Hollywood Reporter they've uh shot fewer
than half of the series 18 episodes so
you less than nine but still quite up
there and but Kevin FY he has reviewed
the footage and Come Away with a cleare
eyed assessment that the show wasn't
working now we heard some rumors of
things like Daredevil wasn't going to
show up in costume until episode 4
there's also been things come out saying
that foggy was killed in the first
episode off camera and oh God just yeah
insane so upset yeah so they will
apparently be using some of the footage
from what they shot and kind of working
it into certain storylines and you know
if they've got an action scene and they
want to have a fight they're like well
we'll just do that but yeah they they
they've basically um brought them all in
and said that in general they realized
that the TV side of Marvel isn't working
and what they had done is basically
instead of getting show Runners they
would just get head writers they
wouldn't create Pilots or stuff like
that and the old television model that's
worked for decades and decades they just
thought ah we don't need to do that
we'll just make basically six-h hour
long movies and chop them up and I think
you can kind of tell that when you're
watching the Marvel shows like if
I've always felt like it's like watching
a movie but the filler scenes are left
in where normally you'd be like oh we
can cut this bit we can cut this bit
they're kind of like well we need to
fill up time for these six episodes so
leave all that stuff in and yeah Marvel
have just hit a point where they
realized that it's not working out and
apparently so far they've spent $150
million on the show and they didn't hire
shunners they depended on film
Executives to run the series and yeah
it's just kind of Hit the point where
they they realize like it's not working
we need to start again which I know
everyone's spinning it like oh it's
terrible um I actually think you know
Daredevil being a complete disaster
behind the scenes is a good thing that
they've realized that and Studios often
get criticized for not listening to fans
like Lucas film's a perfect example of
that where it's like Kathleen Kennedy
will announce a Slater films and they're
like we're telling you we don't want
this and you're still going ahead with
it I actually really respect Marvel and
have faith in them that they're not
blaming fans for Stuff failing they're
not saying like you guys are are ruining
the the universe we created for you
they're they're saying we've made
mistakes we're doing it wrong let's just
start again and clearly they realize how
important of a character that Daredevil
is because those Netflix shows
especially they need to at least match
them in terms of quality those first two
Daredevil seasons are Classics and I
think that if they don't do that they're
going to get so much backlash so I
actually feel good about this you said
those first two Daredevil Seasons you
don't like the third I think three no
three is really good as well that's with
um Bullseye it I watched all of them
quite recently yeah it's good um yeah I
I gotta say uh when we first when we
were first talking about this a few days
ago I was messaging you going I didn't
realize Marvel TV didn't have a show
Runner that is such an essential quality
to and it just kind of clicked for me uh
right then and there because they they a
head riter does not equate to show like
you can have a head Rider without a
showrunner apparently and a showrunner
really helps with everything like the
overall Creative Vision helping to map
out an entire season and they get a lot
of other things in order as well like
the the the task can very much vary from
casting to you know production planning
to all kinds of problem solving but they
are the real leader uh when it comes to
a show think like a Vince Gilligan for
Breaking Bad for example or on a comedy
like a Tina Fay or Chuck Lori for Two
and a Half Men you know there's a whole
bunch of different types of showrunners
out there um but they're involved like
the editing and the post- production and
you know it's it really did seem like
when we talk about committee made that
that term that's often going around with
Marvel you could really feel that with a
lot of the TV shows that I'm surprised
that without a showrunner because
they've had good directors and uh good
head writers I'm surprised that they've
man AG to still at the end of the day
deliver some really great shows
regardless I mean I know a lot of them
can be misses uh but I I think that kind
of it kind of makes more sense now why a
lot of the time the conversation around
many of the TV shows would be it started
off great but then by the time it got to
the end I don't know it just didn't
stick the land and it just didn't quite
get there and I think a showrunner would
really Aid in making sure the the vision
overall is met and you could plan out
for something bigger because it seemed
like before like Loki season 2 is the
first show to have a season two we know
we got what if season two coming up but
that's a little bit more like Anthology
uh while connected it's still a little
bit more Anthology where Loki season 2
is very much a a Serial serialized
narrative and now I think they'd be
planning to have multiple seasons for
stuff like I think Daredevil born again
I've heard reports that they wanted to
do 18 episodes first first season then I
heard that they actually wanted to make
it two seasons with Nine episodes
regardless it's not just dividing up a
movie like they really have to think
about the television viewer engagement
and that's where a showrunner really
does become essential especially for the
long-term planning and I'm surprised
they haven't had it before I'm glad
they're doing it now and I do agree with
you while it's a bummer for those who
did put in the work while it's a bummer
for their work not being able to get
canned and maybe if they were more
popular people like when Lord and Miller
got fired from solo we're like no and
maybe there'd be more of an outrage
towards that if if we were if we if we
really knew the credentials of the
people involved this still does speak a
more volumes to the fact that they are
re-evaluating they are reflecting on the
response that things have been and
knowing that Kevin feige himself was
like look things have got to change like
it comes down to more than just numbers
a lot of it does come down to audience
reception of course and now we can
really get things back on track when
you're dealing with shows it's different
than a movie uh regardless even though
the MCU the films themselves have been
like a television series in its own way
actually doing a TV series is very
different and I do agree with you
because Daredevil is especially out of
them all was was is the one that's being
resurrected or being born again and it
there's there's a a lot more there's a
lot more weight to it because it's going
to be compared to what it did on Netflix
and and you're right it has to at least
bottom line be as good distinguish
itself but also be as good as the
Netflix one was because that out of all
the Netflix shows that is easily the one
that's hell in the highest regard and to
this day it's still my favorite MCU
series of all them I for me it
personally does uh outrank Loki like out
of out of all them so yeah I I think it
has to be great and I love Charlie Cox
and Vincent and afre and stuff so I me I
hope it I hope they nail it I I hope
they nail it and what's been what I've
been basically researching over the
weekend when I haven't been lying on the
floor face down drunk is all of the kind
of stuff that Marvel tend to do Post
production wise so Joanna Robinson I
think Ryan knows her quite well I'm sure
she's appeared on screen crush a couple
of times um she basically put out an MCU
book called The Rain of Marvel Studios
it was a very much she's done so much
good research um there were other author
there were other authors involved but
she's been on the watch podcast talking
about it and kind of going in some of
the insane stuff that Marvel were doing
so they basically brought up how it's
not as planned out as it seems and even
things like Thanos he wasn't supposed to
appear at the end of The Avengers and
Jos Sweden was actually the one who put
that idea forward and Marvel were
apparently so tired of fighting that
they just went yeah whatever and then as
they started to develop it they realized
oh we've got Infinity Stones kind of
dotted about the MCU we can bring them
all together and he was also talking
about the process that Marvel do filming
which sounds absolutely insane so they
don't have a finished script when they
go to shoot they'll make all the scenes
but they'll have scheduled re-shoot and
know that stuff's coming down the line
and they then they'll get those pieces
Pres present them to Kevin fargi who'll
watch them and say okay we need to fill
in this character bit we need to fill in
that character bit we need to tie these
plot threads together and then they'll
then go off and re-shoot all the stuff
in those re-shoot to kind of Tide all
together which is absolutely mental so
they don't sit down with a finished
script or anything it's kind of let's
film lots of different bits give it to
Kevin fargy who then give us feedback
and we'll then go put it together and
basically the the Hollywood um reporter
says that you know they have a whole fix
it in post attitude which makes it feel
like a director doesn't matter um and
that's a quote that's come from one
person familiar with the process and it
says as shows ramped up during the
pandemic Marvel stepped outside its
usual Staffing approach and brought in
outside execs after years of internally
promoting creatives who'd been
sufficiently trained in the Marvel
method um and apparently this change was
felt the most severely on secret
Invasion as they had Kyle Brad street
who had worked on Mr Robot he'd been
doing lots of scripts for secret
Invasion for about a year and then he
was abruptly replaced after Marvel
decided to go in a different direction
and they then got Brian Tucker involved
who Penn the crime Thriller Broken City
and it sounds like they were just
chopping and changing things behind the
scenes so much now we had heard rumors
that basically half of secret Invasion
had been refilmed um there was a
direction that they were going in and
they ended up scrapping it and bringing
new people in and doing it in a
completely different direction and we've
seen how that worked out with that
series I felt they had really strong I
mean I remember being on the podcast
when we were talking about the the
reception to it and we've been like
we've seen the first couple of episodes
and they're great we don't understand
why everyone hates it and then yeah you
can kind of see where it all fell apart
and it just sounds like they've hit a
point where they realize it's damaging
the brand they're not putting out you
know they're putting out they're putting
out okay things but it's not as good as
it could be and it you know over time if
you keep putting out mid project after
mid project not only does it not get you
interested in the characters involved in
it it's also the MCU as a whole where
you kind of like I don't really care
about where this is going anymore it
went from something that felt like you
had to watch it to understand what was
coming and you were enjoying it to
something where it's like well I'm not
enjoying it that much and I don't really
care where this is going and I don't
even know where it's going so yeah I
feel like they tried to catch lightning
in a bottle twice and format it for TV
and it's just not worked out but hearing
this it makes me feel like I'm glad they
realize that you know what I mean as
much as I'm kind of we're we're bashing
on them and saying how bad it is I would
much rather a studio was self-aware
enough to the point where it's like yep
we need to sort this out mate we can't
just keep doing the same old crap
because they they could they could
easily just sit uh you know run this
thing into the ground and not really
care
and just keep knocking out series after
series but I'm glad they're doing what
they're doing and though it it might
come across as we're bashing on them I I
personally think it's a positive thing
yeah I agree I agree with everything
that you said and I do I I do hope that
they can kind of revisit that lesson
that happened with Thanos uh because
that is I think one of the terminologies
for it is called process of discovery
you know the the like I just brought up
Vince Gilligan with Breaking Bad and one
of the big stories about that was the
initial plan was to kill off Jesse
Pinkman uh within the in the first
season in the first few episodes to
elevate Walter White's story and as they
were writing him and as they were
watching Aaron Paul's
performance they were like no we got to
keep him like it completely went against
the showrunners Bible the original Bible
for it because they discovered something
else and that's essentially kind of what
happened happened with you know Thanos
as well like the response happened they
saw an opportunity and from the outside
looking in you would think that that was
the plan the entire time when whenever
we talk about like what's this
Multiverse saga's plan where is Phase 4
and five truly all headed like we know
it's headed to Secret Wars and and and
it's still somehow it doesn't feel as
focused even though we know that it's
headed to to stuff like King Dynasty and
Secret Wars yet the focus feels a little
bit off
and I think having that creative uh
Ingenuity where you can have a little
bit of freedom for discovery which is
again allowing a little bit more of your
creative input with your writers like
you were telling me about the moonnight
headwriter um quitting halfway through
the series production Kate Heron she did
not return while I like the directors
and what Loki season 2 was doing they
wanted to go a different direction and
uh she did not return for Loki season 2
even though she directed like all of
Loki season 1 so there can be a lot of
these creative problems and I think
right now there needs to be a little bit
more Synergy and also communication and
understanding because I it just seems
too apparent OB we've we've probably
beat this point to death a billion times
by now of how a lot of the times like we
need everything needs to be connected
but people working on this project
aren't aware of what's really going on
in this project and yet things need to
be connected and then and Kevin feige
doesn't want to reveal anything so he's
got to like have his little secret
meetings and be like include this and
and a lot s people are going I don't
know why we have to include this but we
have to include it because Kevin feige
said to do it and I I think having more
people involved than on board we need to
embrace the creativity uh once again and
I think it's it's kind of it's kind of
funny it's like a snake eating its own
tail in a way of an Ora boros Ora boros
yes of course great great job there uh
is how you know when the
MCU like I really think that Thanos
moment is so definitive of the of a plan
mixed with creative opportunity is
allowing a door to open it's it's like a
a perfect point and then when you see
like others people try to start
cinematic universes and how much they
failed because they're like trying to
plan everything out and like here's what
everything is supposed to be and while
you need a plan because because Star
Wars Trilogy went the complete opposite
direction and did you need a plan to
sort of be like a guideline in a way and
not necessar scripture but a guideline
and I and I think Marvel kind of fell
into the Trap that other other people
were also doing but they were also kind
of just throwing [__] at the wall and
going let's see what El sticks because
people will eat up anything we're the
MCU we're impenetrable and that's
clearly not the case anymore especially
when you're hearing about [__] like
what's going on with the the Marvel's
box office projections which is not
surprising it's not surprising what's
going on no so the initial box office
projections have it opening to anywhere
between 50 to 75 million meaning that um
it would if it if it hits below 55
million then it'll officially be the
lowest opening weekend for an MCU film
ever even lower than the Incredible Hulk
back in the day when Marvel was first
getting its feet wet it was that was
made by Universal as well um so to come
in lower than that it kind of spells
what the state of the MCU is like at the
moment and and you know it's it's an
opening projection it might change
people might end up you know closer to
the time but what tends to happen is
that the analysts of this who we talk
about all every week on the podcast
they'll look at how other films have
performed they'll then judge the the
interest on pre ticket sales use their
own algorithms and stuff to kind of work
out a figure where it will realistically
fall um Grace Randolf I was listening to
her the other week on beyond the trailer
she was saying that she'd heard that the
the pre- ticket sales were around the
area of The Flash and that's basically
made Marvel completely panic and then
when this projection came out it was
kind of like oh crap that that does uh
that sounds really bad
so it's difficult to kind of guess
because again people might just you know
an advert for them might hit and they
might go oh you know what I am going to
go see it and they might buy tickets
however they might be put off and I kind
of feel like it is going to struggle at
the box office I think um superhero
fatigue I know that's a buzzword but I
think in general we've seen this year
that films on the whole have been
underperforming and I I don't think
necessarily it's you know Captain Marvel
or the Marvel's fault I think in general
at the moment there's kind of a feeling
around comic book movies that they're
all sort of the same at the moment
there's nothing really massively
differentiating them and bar across the
spiderverse yeah we can wait until stuff
hits streaming or do we even need to see
it you know what I mean that I I think
that first Captain Marvel movie it it
hit per it hit at the right time it hit
perfectly and though you know I don't
think I I you know in a vacuum I don't
think Captain Marvel would have been a
billion dollar movie but what happened
was people cared so much about endgame
and what they thought they needed to see
in order to understand that film that
they just went out and droves and went
to see it um and I know people are
suggesting changing the title to to
Captain Marvel 2 but I mean birds are
pre they tried that strategy with it
when they changed it from birds of prey
to Harley Quinn and I don't I think
people are aware enough of it at the
point where it's you know changing the
Marvels to Captain Marvel 2 isn't going
to make a massive difference and people
who are already interested in this stuff
they're going to know it's coming out um
and I feel at the core of this is just a
thing that people it's it's smack you
over the head and people just seem to
avoid it and come up with loads of
reasons why stuff's failing but the
bottom line is people just don't care
yeah and that that's why we're getting
flops like dial of Destiny the recent DC
EU movies and the low projections for
the Marvel is because people just don't
care enough to go out and see it Batman
yeah though I've had 400 movies about
Batman or whatever people care about
Batman so any Batman movie that comes
out people are like I care about Batman
man I'm going to see it um and in the
case of this I just don't think you know
the studios are selling you the idea
with these films why you should care
like there's not even in the Marvel's
trailer there's not really that money
shot to make you think oh crap you know
what I mean and the fact they're not
building up to something as well and
we're all kind of lost I know Secret
Wars is coming but you can't really
figure out how this ties into it it's
it's kind of like what why do I have to
care enough about this film to go out
and see it and I just don't feel like
they're they're hitting that home run um
and it you know caring about stuff is is
solely the reason that Studios buy up
old IPS because it's easier to make a
sequel or a requel or reboot of a
franchise that people already care about
than to try and get them to care about
something that they've never seen before
and we've seen that in the case of the
Creator and you you needs that hook you
need that hook with a movie where people
are hooked into it and they want to go
out and see it up and high
is the perfect example you know directed
by any other person in Hollywood there's
no way that movie comes close to making
anywhere near a billion dollars you know
it's a black and white biop pick about a
historical figure making the atom bomb
it doesn't have like fights it it's not
an action movie it's three hours long
it's very you know it's it's not
something on paper that you would think
if you give this to any director it's
going to make anywhere close to that
amount of money but people care about
what Christopher Nolan's doing next they
really want to see it it's the same with
James Cameron people care about that
director and so when they hear about
that movie coming they're going to go
out and see it um and I think Studios
just need to remember make us make us
care about it because at the moment you
know it doesn't feel like even they care
that much like I've not really seen that
much marketing for it I've seen a couple
of posters and stuff but where's where's
the cell to make go oh you I need to see
the Marvels we're going to talk about
the SAG strike in a little bit and this
is one of those movies because they have
three different uh they have a crossover
of these three different personalities
coming to the big screen together um
from three different properties W Vision
Captain Marvel and Miss Marvel where I I
like oh I do think if the SAG strike was
over the the promotion of because
sometimes you're like ah the promotion
of the actors probably doesn't really
matter you know sometimes you really it
doesn't matter I think for this it would
have actually made a dent I think it
could have helped Elevate the box office
because the main thing that if you watch
the trailers for this the the main thing
that I have is like yeah it looks it
looks somewhere between fine to fun you
know what I mean like it looks f it
looks fun I I'll give it that it doesn't
look great to me or groundbreaking by
any stretch but the best I can say about
it and I think what a lot of people will
say is yeah it looks fun and that's
something that a lot of people just kind
of want is I just want a fun movie the
thing though
is just fun is not enough to get people
in the seats for theaters anymore
especially for a comic book movie I
think we all know that the box office
reports for so many of the superhero
movies and [__] and even some of the
viewer numbers on some of these things
uh it's a testament to all that
you needed to feel a little bit special
so fun isn't just going to cut it
anymore so I I feel like yeah maybe it
might not do well in theaters and a lot
of people might just have the mentality
of just waiting for it to come out on
Disney Plus or video on demand and I
think if you really want to sell people
on fun what really would have helped is
if you do a bunch of those interviews
with you know um the three of them just
having a ball together and really
promoting their [__] out of this movie
as just a genuine blast of a film and I
think that would have made a difference
so I really think while they like
they're not competing with Dune um
there's there's not there's really not
much competition for that I don't really
know what they're even the Hunger Games
is out is not the same weekend hung
games is coming out it's it's in the
same month oh yeah it's I think it's the
weekend after but I mean that's going to
cause a drop the these films tend to do
that number first weekend and then
roughly it's about a 60% week second
weekend drop so dropping down from that
it's going to really really have a
difficult time especially with that
Hunger Games Film which I don't know if
that's going to do that well I'm in the
same problem with that where I'm just
not sure if they're selling why we
should care and obviously you know not
having the actors on board that's that's
a major problem but even still I I don't
feel that the movie would knock out the
park I I could never see it grossing
close to a billion like that first
Captain Marvel did I I'm looking at
numbers right now and I just realized
Black Widow that opened to $80 million
and that was during the pandemic where
they also had the option where you could
just buy it on Disney on Disney plus and
and watch it that way so if this opens
under black widow that's a really really
really bad sign because it is
technically a sequel to Captain Marvel
which is a billion dollar hit but I
don't know I mean if you change to
Captain Marvel 2 it still doesn't even
even though Captain Marvel's in it it
still doesn't feel like a Captain Marvel
2 to me at least with what the trailers
are doing it's like a continuation of
everyone's story from what we saw in W
division Miss Marvel and Captain Marvel
so I don't I don't feel like it' be
accurate to call it it would be like
calling Captain America Civil War
Captain America 3 like you needed that
subtitle to it where you're like you
know it's a Captain America 3 but
it's not just the sequel to Winter
Soldier even though a lot of ways it was
just a sequel to Winter Soldier for the
Captain America story um yeah I don't
know I feel like it's got uphill yeah
you also have it coming I mean M Marvel
I really enjoy M Marvel I think it's
like got a 98% rating on Rotten Tomatoes
but we know the viewing figures haven't
been there secret in it's sort of a
sequel to secret Invasion as well
because of the Nick Fury stuff and we
know there's going to be elements of the
scrolling and meeting with the cre for a
pece summit or whatever it is it's kind
of a sequel of that and they're not the
best foundation to build sequels on and
obviously Miz Marvel again really like
it but the viewership wasn't there
secret Invasion didn't have good
viewership and it's I think it's the
lowest rated MCU show so it's going to
be it's it's difficult it has got its
work set out for it you know it might do
well might hit people at the right time
they're looking for a fun film but I
just feel like the comic book movies at
the moment they need just a bit more to
them than just this fun wacky stuff
because even with Marvel we've seen how
that's not really been working that well
in the likes of Thor love and thunder
Antman and the was quom Mania you know
they get sold as fun wacky movies and
we've almost been let down too many
times by that style of thinking from the
studio like they came out and apparently
said that they thought Ant Man in the
was qu Mania was going to be a banger
and they were really surprised when
people didn't like it um and it's like
you your internal barometer off a bit
mate if you think that the audience who
who likes Infinity War endgame Winter
Soldier first Iron Man movie you know if
they thought that was going to be
something they'd really really enjoy so
yeah bit of a strange time at the studio
um apparently Wonder man's being
cancelled as well I think they're just
having a big overhaul which again we
we're slagging them off but it's it's
for the best in the long run I think
personally I I can see it working out
well if they're just self-aware of
things like we do all the time as well
we'll you know do a series of videos and
be like you know that didn't quite have
the desired effect I wanted and it's
time to just scrap the entire podcast
and do something else because it ain't
working especially that co-host who
everyone once dead I don't know what
you're talking about yeah just nothing
um so moving on to more fun stuff um
Aquaman 2 gez it's had one of the worst
like if you thought Marvel's PR was bad
at the moment you haven't heard anything
yet this is genuinely one of the worst
things of PR that I've ever seen a
studio have to deal with before film's
coming out and there was a massive
report dropped by variety last week
talking about how Aquaman 2 was flooded
with drama Jason Mamoa allegedly was
drunk on set Amber herd had all the
scenes cut Elon Musk apparently had to
step in and write a letter you should
have sent an X you wrote a letter to WB
saying I'm going to destroy the entire
studio if you don't give Amber herd a
role in Aquaman 2 and yeah insane Greg
what what your thoughts we'll go through
it bit by bit but what are your thoughts
is it is it gonna be a good movie is it
gonna do well is a disaster honestly it
makes me want to watch the movie even
more like I I thought the trailer was
fine we've talked about it that it
looked like it didn't feel like that
different from the first movie to me uh
but this just makes me go I I'm I'm
actually hoping it's a bit of a disaster
because they've already come out and
said at least according to this article
right that none of the original Justice
League members are returning that
includes Jason Mamoa as Aquaman he's not
coming back so they're just doubling
down on making this feel more um
non-essential uh and I I think this was
this this lines up with was some didn't
Amber her say something along the lines
of what was here like during the trials
of like uh they try to get her fired and
[__] and now Jason like I've heard these
rumors before I feel like I feel like
this is just
more I don't know it's exactly
confirmation but it's resurrected
information that seems like there's more
to it than there was Prior so what
happened was on the day that the Aquaman
trailer dropped Johnny Depp fans or um
some someone connected to them who who
basically crowdfunded this they paid for
the release of documents from Amber
herd's therapist Dr Dawn Hughes and
they've kind of went through all these
notes talked about you know it's
basically what the therapist has has
jotted down about what Amber said is
happening on the set of Aquaman um so
apparently yeah Jason Mamoa wanted her
fired and we did hear about this during
the trial um I think Walter Hamada had a
big thing where he talked about how they
were going to fire Amber herd because
you just didn't have chemistry and then
yeah they they were kind of kicking
about the idea it didn't have anything
to do with any of the dep controversy
you know Amber herd had been saying that
because of Johnny Depp's um suing her
for defamation that Warner Brothers have
kind of [__] the bed and decided to fire
her because of it or cut her down from
the movie Walter hamal was saying that's
not the case she was always gonna have
either a cut down role or be fired and
then apparently Elon Musk stepped in
said don't do that um otherwise I'm
going to write nasty things about you
and bring the whole studio crashing down
you know oh they're doing that whatever
you think about
that yeah weird weird way to go about it
um
but Jason Mamoa basically he was trying
to get her fired the entire time she
said he was showing up drunk and
apparently he was also dressing like
Johnny her kind of dresses like Johnny
de does doesn't he like and he and
there's a lot of times where he's like
posing with beer in his hands likes to
drink so it just doesn't to me it
doesn't I I have no idea like I'm not on
set I don't know the specifics of the
story it's you know it's but I'm saying
that when I when I hear that my first
thought is doesn't he always kind of
dress like Johnny Depp and doesn't he
people already know He the guy likes to
drink so I don't know if it has specific
I mean showing up drunk on set is not a
good thing uh I guess my question is is
it really just to antagonize uh amber
I'm not defending him with it I'm just
more questioning if it is yeah but
people say I dress like Star-Lord from
Guardians of the Galaxy volume two to
try and annoy you but I don't see that
myself oh my God you do but um image the
way that the studi kind of went no the
not the studios the way the media went
with it was that it's like Jason Mamoa
shows up drunk on the set of Aquaman
dressed as Johnny Depp to try and get
Amber herd fired and it's like well no
these are actually statements that Amber
herd
to therapist you know there's two sides
every story and Jason M moa's reps have
deined to comment but a DC spokesperson
pushed back on the characterization and
said Jason mam conducted himself in a
professional manner at all times on the
set um Jason works his ass off likes to
have a beer once in a while like
everyone but he doesn't show up to the
set drunk um heard declined to comment
and yeah it's just it's just a complete
disaster I mean imagine trying to
promote a movie yeah you trying to
promote a movie where you're like
Aquaman and mea they're in love they've
got a family but it's all going to get
brought CR Crashing Down by Black Manta
it's like mate Black Manta don't even
need to show up to destroy this family
it's like it's over that we know that
actors hate each other it's gonna it's a
disaster and just for the fact that
they're going with the strategy again of
none of this [__] matters mate none
don't worry about seeing this movie
because we were rebooting it soon um
yeah is not just not a good thing to
happen before a film is due to release
and we've still got months left before
it comes out and well just another
disaster for DC it's a complete disaster
well I was hearing from Jeff Snider uh
who has the hot Mike and Snider podcast
and he a lot of his Scoops tend to be
correct like he's one of those people
who but like I'm sure he's wrong once in
a while whatever everyone is but in
terms of the scoop business he tends to
be tends to be really good he's got a
good track record and he was saying that
yeah you know um Jason MO is going to be
Lobo they they they were talks about him
you know trying to get a cameo or an
appearance in uh Superman Legacy
potentially set him up for a solo film
and the the prediction is that they were
they're going to announce that he's Lobo
in February or March which to me is not
a good idea still like you it seems
inevitable I'd be very surprised if if
Aquaman to does well I be at this point
I'd be surprised I'm not saying it's for
sure going to flop it just seems likely
it's not going to do
well and to go off of a flop and then
immediately go hey we're bringing back
jasm Mo he's going to be a different I I
don't feel like doing it so soon after
if they do decide to do I think they
should hold off longer to announce it
it's everyone's already kind of
speculating on it you got to let that
desire simmer to see deny yeah get the
denials in have Jason M Mo go no I'm not
doing it I'm not doing it be get people
begging for to come back you know what I
mean get people bag it yeah that's what
you got to do you got to build it up you
got to get the anticipation going Sizzle
it and then announce it but if you
announce it like following a a disaster
I don't think that's the way to get
people excited about Jason Mamoa joining
the DC Universe and if anything I feel
like that might just lead to more you
know negative speculation and negative
rumors and like yeah Jason M wanted this
to fail or some [__] you know like I
I have no idea what what it could open
the door for but I don't think it's a
good idea to announce it so soon seems
inevitable he's going to be Lobo but but
I feel like they should hold off longer
yeah but I was actually glad to hear
that they're going with an all new
Justice League lineup I get called a
Snider shill all the time I get called a
d James Gunter all the time but I do
think that they need to just take as
much attention away from being connected
to this universe as possible let's be
honest guys you know it hasn't been well
managed it hasn't been well run and I
think James gun you know he he I don't
like the way that he's announcing stuff
in advance when he doesn't need to but I
think this is the right direction to
take things where you're getting a whole
new Justice League lineup you're not you
you're severing the attachments to it
and you're keeping some things but not
necessarily leaning into them that much
like Blue Beetle I know we're getting
told he's being kept but I I just feel
like that they saw the box office and
stuff and we're like well we'll get him
in a team up movie I enjoyed Blue Beetle
really liked sho's performance um but I
feel like they they need to more build
them up amongst the other Heroes to kind
of prop them up and be like look this is
a new guy he's standing shoulder toos
shoulder with these Giants pay attention
to him and I think the way they're doing
it at the moment is you know once they
get past Aquaman to I think it's going
to be sunlit Uplands as we say in the UK
and yeah they've got the potential there
to do something special I think if they
just sever this and go yep we were
telling you you need to watch it but it
was all PR baby we're back new Justice
League Cas an announcement we've got I
don't know Josh John Ham is an older
Batman and his kid is played by Timothy
Olan oh not Timothy Timothy sham that
would be weird if it
was it's because I yeah it's because I
was listening to that
sh yeah and they were saying that
Timothy olant was initially really far
along in terms of Iron Man casting and
then at the last second they decided to
go with uh Robert Downey Jr instead I
also heard to to put this to rest um I
heard that the there's there's that the
WB might be selling again that that it's
gonna it might go through to Universal
to Universal and then you get new
leadership and
then they might just get James gun's DC
Universe if it's not panning out well
all we might just get yet another
announcement another reboot um so I I
can't like WB is getting tossed around
man man that is it's whing WB is just
whing itself around to every Studio out
there it's kind of crazy it's kind of
nuts what's going on with them it's just
all been mismanagement from the start
they just didn't have a clear Direction
even stuff that's been coming out where
it was like Zack Snyder was sort of
going to make his own Trilogy and it was
when they realized how well Marvel were
doing with this connected Universe they
were basically like Zach you need to
make it connected to Universe you can't
just have these characters off on their
own so I can't remember where I heard it
it was someone who is actually connected
to these films I think it might have
been David es but he was talking about
how just in the same way that Nolan made
his own Batman
Trilogy Snider was going to do his own
thing where it was just going to be
self-contained and then he kind of got
forced onto a path of you have to make a
plan for a Cinematic Universe because
the you're the person who's kind of
holding the Hot Potato at the moment
when we're trying to do this thing so
yeah it's just been kind of
mismanagement from the start and I think
you know the the article itself it has
the perfect quote which is everyone's
down on DC but that well the quote kind
of goes off but there is a chance
especially with the limited competition
during the holiday season that Aquaman
could still play Gang Busters because of
lack of product which I disagree with I
think um yeah I think they've kind of
shut themselves in the foot and the pr I
believe the pr is going to get worse as
we get closer to the film because
everyone's sitting on those hot Scoops
those big stores
that they just want to drop and say you
know Jason M Mo goes out and does the
press for it and Amber herd's not there
it's just going to start so many rumors
and people are just going to jump on it
for clicks like we will oh my God I
can't wait yeah it's be a time for
profit at the heavy Spoilers Podcast
well I think you were trans were you
transitioning us maybe I guess we were I
was coughing away with my mic muted so
the guys didn't have to listen to it oh
but you're right go the SAG after an
amtp those negotiations have hit a snag
the studios don't think it's reasonable
for the actors to get 2% of the
streaming revenue and there's no
agreement yet on the use of AI and that
comes from the LA
Times so not very good we thought we
stupidly said last week Greg well
they've got the deal this is yeah I
don't think it's good negotiation yeah
if you go if you negotiating with two
parties I personally don't think it's a
negot like to go to one and be like yeah
we'll give you everything you want mate
whatever you want we're at your mercy
have have everything have even more and
then go to the next people and be like
oh you know what can't can't do it mate
sorry gonna have to reject the deal um
so what they've apparently that the deal
they brought to the table is actually
worse than the first deal I took to the
table um months ago which is very it's a
very bold strategy cotton let's see if
it pays off for
them so uh yeah it's stuff's been really
kicking off um the Hollywood labor
they've released a joint statement
supporting sag and they've basically
called on the studios to resume
negotiations and yeah they've uh sag
have revealed that the CEOs have refused
to do it and won't offer any counter
offers in terms of the last one they got
so what what like are you playing at you
literally had everything you had the the
ball rolling I think what you talking
about what you doing I think they know
exactly what they're doing like just
think about the trajectory of everything
I'm gonna put on my tinf foil hat here
for a
second because it just kind of makes
sense to me all right I'm admitting this
is this is all little conspiracy Gregory
right
here first thing they agreed with that
they got done before everything was like
the directors didn't even have to go on
strike they got to deal with the
directors so that makes it look like hey
we're want to play ball right and then
the Hol uh the rider strike happens same
thing we're not meeting a the hell with
you guys really we're just going to
bounce in the middle of this meeting I
don't like what you're asking for
there's no way in hell you're going to
get this and then they come back
eventually and then they writers end up
getting more of what they want and
that's kind of what's been happening
with sag same thing right and a big part
of me has been
like they've been having flopp after
flop they need [__] to be cancelled at
the end of the day you know when when
after all the strikes are done they can
get back to filming and things they have
to can or or removed they could blame a
lot of failures on the strike situation
get people out of contract because a lot
of times when you like agree to all
these countless TV shows you're doing
and movies you got sequel Bargains and
sequel deals or season renewals on on
hand all this [__] that you can like now
get out of you can can a lot of things
from this and they're able to save
themselves a lot of money so right now
with buying some time they could have
the writers be writing while it does
cost them some stuff they could also be
saving some money simultaneously on this
and it's all a Big Bargain strategy uh
to me so part of me is like I think this
is like they have a pattern here what
amptp does there's a pattern to how they
to how they're doing it stupidity it's
it's it's silly it's stupid but I feel
like there's a long con here uh there's
a there a feeling of sub no cuz they
agree to everything that they say they
give them everything they want event
reason there's delay completely I feel
like there's a reason why they they they
prolong this delay because it allows
them to what's up I thought that but
then I realized now they were in the
middle of shooting so many projects that
they then had to stop and like Deadpool
3 were in the middle of shooting that
yeah there's so many projects that they
were in the middle of shooting that they
could just get back to shooting they
don't need the writers on them and
instead they're going to have a backlog
of stuff because they delay this [__] so
much when they are going to agree it's
like good luck making movies without the
actors guys you really really thinking
this one through I don't re I don't
think they realize they're [__] right
they have no they have nothing to bring
to the table really um other than
dragging this thing out let's be honest
they will just agree to their terms
eventually where where I think they're
because I think what they ask for
because like you're right like that's
the other side of I have two feelings to
it one feeling is conspiracy Greg is
like I feel like there's something
bigger here here where they're saving
some money somehow and the other side is
but for the information we get they're
also losing money right because they're
they're putting these Productions on
hold and they have to pay the cost for
all that [__] and they could be making
these so I have like two feelings about
it and I don't know which way to fully
lean um so to my
understanding um they they they asked
for something in regards to the
residuals uh I don't know the exact
number uh when it came to the streaming
of like 50 something cents uh per
subscriber the idea was that was it a
dollar per subscriber oh was it was it a
dollar okay um then whatever that amount
is they would then that would go to Sag
and then sag would be the ones who would
divy it up it's not like every person
gets that amount of money you know like
they would find the way to divvy it up
and that was their way of proposing
something to allow some form of residual
because they got to figure out the
residual game in some capacity they just
have to figure it out so that was what
they proposed now a lot of people
obviously are like that's a ridiculous
ask and to ask it so late into
negotiations what a [__] thing to do
so late into negotiations to ask for
something well that the whole point is
to negotiate though the whole point is
to bargain the whole point is to discuss
and go okay well then counter offer what
do you propose in return as well to just
I don't know what the what these
meetings are I don't know how heated
it's it's getting in these rooms where
the the talk is that they thep members
are like I'm out of here and they just
like storm out that they they should be
there discussing dishing it out even if
it's getting heated you should be
talking it out and have counter offers
going even if you don't like if you
don't like that offer even if we don't
like that offer like I'm not saying I do
or I don't know what the right number is
for this [__] but if it's not good there
has to be a counter because you have to
find
some type of agreement and commonality
on this particular issue I think the AI
thing I I don't feel like that's ever
going to I don't think actors will ever
concede to something like that I think
that's just way too that's a big ask and
I and I feel like there's a dangerous
terrain there and I I don't feel like
the actors will ever conceded that the
residuals though it's it's become way
too apparent that actors don't get like
jack [__] when it comes to residuals and
when a lot of shows get a second life on
streaming or when a lot of shows uh
find their life on streaming like
Breaking Bad it's a third time bringing
this up they don't get anything from it
and I think yeah suit Su is like the
biggest streaming show in the world
right now and how long ago did that
finish and it's just constantly if you
look at any of the neelon charts suits
is at the top at the moment and it's got
to the point where they're talking about
doing a Revival now do they get then
give the residual to the actors they're
like NOP we paid you on the day mate we
I know we agre to stuff in the contract
but the the models changed now with
streaming go s yourself yeah I don't I
don't know what it would I don't know
what the answer would be but the the the
answer is not getting mad and leaving
like that's not the answer yeah you know
sometimes when it's like talks break
down and negotiations have ceased I
would just say
look cool down mate come back tomorrow
we'll sort it out yeah just have a think
on it overnight don't talks don't need
breakdown just we'll come back and we'll
sort it because remember we're all
trying to pull in the same direction and
get movies and stuff made for profit I
just can't see the actors backing down
at all I think the studio has shown with
the writers that they they will
eventually just agree to the terms if
they drag it out long enough and I know
the the studios were like but we'll just
keep doing it until they lose their
houses like you you're a piece of [__]
mate for saying that and you're never
going to seem like the good guy in this
situation and all it's going to do is um
hold and the people against you to last
you out even longer they're getting
donations from Big actors The Rock I
know he donated a lot of money there's
been so so many things in their C to
kind of keep them afloat and I think the
studios just see it as a short-term
profit thing where it's like well we'll
do this in the short like we'll deny
these terms because short term we're
going to make a lot of money whereas I
think the actors see it as fighting for
the future of the profession and the
industry if they sign over to this AI
thing boom that's a lot of people's
careers [__] that's dangerous stuff
completely destroyed exactly and that's
why I don't think they're going to
concede because it's bigger than the
strikes whereas the studio don't see it
as that they just see it as like we want
to make money the next three years when
we've got this contract in place it's
bigger for the actors than it is for the
the studio and that's why they're not
going to back down yeah I agree it's too
bad and I think main thing too that a
lot of people want to talk about is like
they haven't had a minimum wage increase
in forever and they they really I think
I think they' they might have agreed to
something already on that that's a
really important aspect for actors as
well like I think what they're asking
for to be increased to is just
$1,350 per day I think that's the exact
number I'm not I remember that correctly
um 1350 per day so you think about it
like how much time do actors spend like
there's there's there's like over close
to like 200,000 people or something like
150,000 people in Sag and most of them
are like don't work consistently and a
lot of them have to you know spend a lot
of money on drive time and gas and going
to on auditions and head shots they they
already put down like a lot of money and
then that 1350 usually have to give like
uh 25% on average away for agent and
manager fees on top of all that you know
so they they're asking for a bigger
minimum wage increase as they deserve to
because it's been it's been like a
couple of decades or something to that
effect and uh I hope they do get that I
think I like I said like I don't know if
the residual ass that they put down for
the streaming thing was the right call
uh however there needs to be something
and they need andp needs to offer
something that is that is workable yeah
yeah well that's why you negotiate it's
kind of like you need to come to the
table and be like look we know you're
ask for this here's the terms we'll meet
you on we
feel strongly that we can do that and we
can work together on that maybe some
things you know we're going to have to
talk about and see if we can can can
kind of come to an agreement on it but
saying that as well you've already shot
yourself in the foot because you agree
to everything with the writers so your
negotiation power you don't have it as
much anymore because it's like well why
could you agree to that but not this um
and I think the actors will just you
know drag things out and you know that
that residual thing maybe I think the AI
thing is something they will get the
studios to agree to because they'll hit
a point where it's like well you know
you're going to kill the entire acting
profession because you're just going to
have like there was that Viral clip this
week of the the CGI crowd in that TV
show and it just looked so bad and yeah
I think I mean we we get accused of both
sides in it sometimes but I think we've
made our position pretty clear like we
do try and at least see things from both
sides but we also definitely have a
favorite one that we always weiding with
one I would say yeah yeah we're we're
trying to say it from your point of view
mate we get it yeah there's money
involved it's stressful for everyone in
I what I think people last time I said I
can imagine it's stressful for everyone
involved I got a lot of backlash for
saying that but I mean we are clearly
siding with the actors but you know it's
I'm gonna both I'm on both sides of it
again we'll just move on we'll move on
should so yeah next no it's it's
important to read feedback and
understand when you're being a [__]
so I want to thank you guys for
commenting and while you're down in the
comments if you could either hit the
like button just maybe not hit the
dislike but move over to the Subscribe
button and hit that as well um so
speaking of tired out old things in
Hollywood Halloween the rights to it
have been bought by mirax and apparently
there's a new Cinematic Universe with
Michael I was really hoping A2 before we
get it I was really hoping a24 oh man
yeah I was like oh they could do
something but to be honest I think it's
for the best that they didn't because
they are actually creative and I think
once they start making that Halloween
money they might go into the old
Hollywood mindset of like well old IPS
actually make us way more money than
green lighting Indie original scripts
let's do that instead so maybe it's for
the best that they didn't win it because
you know they're probably not going to
see that as a successful model in
anytime soon anyway so they might stick
to might stick to the old ways that have
been working for them well which is
brand new scripts uh original properties
and you know that's what a24 has built
itself off of I kind of feel like we
should have listened to lorri stro all
those times that she taught us you know
Michael it keeps coming back and it's
like yeah even though he put him a meat
grinder last time he still still keeps
popping up and I feel like jam Lee
Curtis is just going to be satting room
in the next movie at like 90 years old
or whatever she's not that old but she's
going to be sat there going I try to
warn you Michael would come back it's
like yeah we know we've seen all the
reboots in the sequels love we know he
constantly comes back even though he's
dead the still studi being like man if
only there was a way to come up with a
generic Hollywood slasher film starring
a guy with a white mask um but we can't
come up with it we'll have to buy the
rights to Halloween it's too soon man
too soon for this Halloween [__] too
soon that's my take would it been a
reboot yeah with it been a reboot again
I mean we just finished the last reboot
of Halloween we don't need another
[__] reboot there's been so many
different timelines I've been working on
a big Halloween breakdown um for the
original film and I'm really proud of
the video but one of the funniest things
I found when researching it was John
Carpenter said that he didn't think
there he didn't the reason he didn't do
the sequels is because he didn't think
there was any room to tell a sequel and
the story had kind of run out he was
like boy was I wrong it's like yeah
because the amount of [__] they milk
from this is absolutely insane like I
like the Halloween movies as much as
anyone else but not exactly
groundbreaking at this point to just
have the guy show up to Haden field and
kill people and then get beaten at the
end and disappear into the night see
yeah obviously mirror Max must see the
value in that I think it's I think
announcing a Cinematic Universe again
what the before You' even made the first
film Halloween
cinematic what is what is that supposed
to be unless you have like multiple IPS
you I mean who do mirax own do they own
people I'm not aware of right now like
can you cross them over with other
people yeah maybe they do a scream
crossover or sh they own scream but you
don't need to I think they own scream
yeah I don't know
I'm not a massive slasher fan to be
honest I kind of I enjoy them in small
doses I prefer a more psychological
thilla horror sort of thing I love the
scream franchise I really love the scre
yeah so scream scream the first three
were distributed by mirax so maybe
they're kind of seeing it as as that um
they can kind of get back into the
slasher genre I mean screams had a big
reboot and that's came back successful
they
Hellraiser
um they have don't
breathe they can uh there's there's
there's probably something cool they can
do I imagine um but I don't know I don't
know what the Halloween Cinematic
Universe is because seems that whenever
you stray away from Michael Myers it
doesn't go over well with audiences like
Season of the Witch maybe has Season of
the Witch has had a lot of uh it's
developed a cult following like there's
a lot more love for it and
understandably so and I think the
problem was they made that a part three
you know and instead like you don't just
go one two and then just really try to
change the formula and so they did that
and then I mean Halloween uh what what
was the last ends Halloween ends uh very
divisive I really didn't like it I know
a lot of people really love what they
did with it and I I loathed that film I
really didn't like it and I could under
I've heard both I've heard like some
wonderful video essays on Halloween ends
of of people who are very much Pro for
it that I'm like oh so I can at least I
can at least definitely see why people
would really like that film um at the
end of the day though I feel like it did
not go over that well with people so uh
yeah and that was one where they really
deviated from you know a true Michael
Myers story I know it's Up For Debate
but at the end of the day he's barely in
the film
uh I don't I don't know what they would
do here that could really make it fresh
they tried remaking it with Rob Zombie
that didn't go over that well even
though I actually kind of enjoyed that
first one um no the first one did it was
kind of the second where it fell apart
second was like a wild just mean film um
the that I walked out of the second one
the first time I saw it uh I just I was
like 20 minutes into it once he started
eating a dog I realized is like I don't
really want to watch this movie right
now I eventually put it on in home and
like back and then finish it but that
was one of the few movies I walked out
of her well he eats a dog in the
original but you don't see him eat the
dog like he's he's it was just so it was
just so not a movie I was in the mood
for when I was watching it the second
time when I was watching part two in the
theaters I was like this is just so mean
and I'm not none of this is like
enjoyable at all now he's eating a dog
I'm like I just don't want to be in the
theater right now eventually finished it
I was like I I'll eventually watch it um
but I don't know I like the Halloween
franchise I just think that if you're
going to do a Cinematic Universe I don't
know what the hell that means like who
what other characters have really what
are you gonna do a
doctor uh what's Lumis you g do a Lumis
movie An Origin tale of lumus like what
are you going to do that that would make
an intriguing universe but I'd love to
be wrong I would love to be wrong yeah I
feel the Halloween franchise has run its
course at this point I think we've had
enough reboots remakes and sequels to
the point where you kind of you know
it's kind of it's run its course um
whatever ending to the Michael Myers
franchise you want it's out there I'm
guessing I wasn't a fan of Halloween NZ
there I actually really liked Halloween
kills I thought it was just nice over
the top had some good flashback stuff
yeah all that I wasn't taking it
seriously but you know I enjoyed
watching it um and yeah it's kind of I
feel like it's kind of run its course to
be starting again I mean I I feel like
jam Lee Curtis is so attached to the
franchise as well that they're gonna
have to bring her back but it's almost
like how many times is she going to go
through this and and reboot the
character and Revitalize it's it's kind
of kind of on its course at the moment
and I just don't see how they're going
to build this into a cinematic Universe
where people still care because we've
all seen all the different Halloween
reboots and yeah like you said before I
think it's too close to to start again
and have people still care about it
because we always get let down by them
there's always a good first film in that
reboot and then you know they kind of
limp along might might make a good one
and then you know interest slowly
declines over time love the 2018 speak I
love that 2018 I really I would say I
love that one I really love it well
that's yeah that's what I mean you know
when they buy the rights to this stuff
they tend to have a really good first
idea of how they're going to use it and
utilize it but they don't necessarily
have things mapped out to the point
where it's like we're going to make so
many bangers in this franchise it's only
like we'll make one good one good one
and then it's like oh crap we need to
follow with the sequel what the hell
we're going to do and yeah that's kind
of where the quality tends to fall down
but I like kills I know people don't but
I would much rather watch that over
Halloween ends and our last story is uh
we are not ending until you let me talk
about Taylor so this is the last story
but not the last topic I'm forcing this
in here Paul I'll just stop recording
Noe yeah so yeah War Davis he's said I
meet lovely people on a daily basis who
are fans of hash Willow who are the
reason the Disney plus series was made
don't think it was necessarily that made
I think uh Disney's kind of defunct of
ideas and they're just snake eating
their own tail at the moment and they're
looking at any IP that got and and
greenlighting it but we'll move on um
please tell me he's tagged them minute
please tell me at Walt Disney Co what do
I say to these subscribers when they ask
why they can't watch the series anymore
hash embarrassing so in case you guys
don't know there was a willow series
green lit dropped on Disney plus six
months later they took it off the
platform and you can't watch it again
unless you know some uh some people who
move in certain circles or you've got a
link to a website where you might be
able to see certain TV series for free
what what's your thought on this gr cuz
he actually got a lot of backlash to it
he got backlash to this this is because
you made it we're just saying like yeah
because you made a crap show and that's
why they took it off oh [__] that and I
feel I feel bad for the guy [__]
yeah no it's not no hell with that I
didn't watch it I heard it was bad I
didn't watch it but I think I think
people people put a lot of their heart
and soul and really work their asses
bottom line is people work their asses
off to put this together and at the end
of the day it did have a fan base yeah
even if the fan base wasn't large it did
have a fan base and um and some people
will like it there'll be people out
there who like it I mean even if like
90% of the audience hate it you know
that 10% that enjoyed it why can't why
can't they just have this thing I don't
understand the mats between how it's
cheaper it works out better financially
to write a show cast it film it do all
the postprocess stuff editing it promote
it on a on a platform Market it and then
pull it I don't understand why the
pulling it that makes sense MoneyWise I
don't understand that part why yeah why
that why I mean there must be there must
be an accountant out there who's like
look mate I know you spent these
hundreds of millions of dollars but uh
the most the cleverest thing to do is
actually not show it to anyone because
they're doing that with other series as
well where they finished the entire
thing they're like nope just cheap
better not release it makes more sense
and not release it and make any money
back so yeah it felt kind of bad for the
guy um but I think it just speaks to the
state of streaming at the moment and how
everything's sort of
content and if it don't do well mate
it's off the platform how much of those
servers cost a day to run 20 P it's too
expensive bullet up it doesn't even give
it an opportunity to to like obtain a
fan base one day you know when you just
do that like maybe it didn't get it now
but who knows it could have possibly
grown or something like doesn't matter
bottom line is people put their work
into that as a lot it wasn't just like a
oneoff thing you know they it's like
multiple episodes they re it there's a
lot of creativity and a lot of hard work
put into that from countless people so
many people to just bring a few hours to
life and to just excise it like that I
think it's and to not really give an
answer as to why I think is really
it it allows no real um you know what's
the word when you're what's the word
when you like want to break closure has
a real closure to to the situation and I
think having closure would help at least
with the creatives and for like Warwick
Davis as well I think it no I don't
agree with this whole like it's because
your show sucks thing I'm like even if
it does even if you think that uh there
are people who watch cons if your
mentality is well that shows [__] and it
was woke and we I hated it so I'm glad
they got rid of it let's pretend it's
not Willow let's pretend it's a show you
really like you personally really like
um and then you just found out from the
C you went go watch it they've just
pulled it down you see what I'm saying
you've got a it's not just Willow it's
not we're not just talking about Willow
it's the practice in general of just
removing shows yeah exactly
so don't think about it being Willow
that you hate think about it being a
show that you like and then you'll see
where kind of falls down but and don't
also be like I only like good shows
there will be some stuff in there mate
that you like that [__] we all have
those shows that we that are absolutely
[__] and it's like man I could stop
watching mared Married at First Sight
every week what you mean they've taken
it down that was I need to find out what
happened so yeah that's uh that's the
stories guys we're cut we're end that
there's not nothing else to talk about
this week I've told too many people on
social media I'm doing it on the podcast
it's my way of driving traffic to here
Paul I am going to do this you're gonna
let me you're gonna let me ramble
monologue ah I'm ready I'm gonna go for
it try not to fall asleep Paul that's
your challenge sound like you're ready
that's your challenge for today alrighty
guys so here's where it all began the
Taylor Swift errors tour it is the
number one movie in the world right now
number one
experience I'm going to backtrack this
for a little bit of how I be how I um
how I discovered Taylor Swift I've
always admired her like my wife is
obsessed with her I've always admired
her but I was never really into her
music I've always had I'm one of those
guys who's always had like a wall up
against um whenever I would try to
listen to her like whenever I put her on
it would be that kind of thing you know
when someone overhypes a movie or a show
and you're just sort of waiting around
like all right one's is GNA be amazing
one's is gonna be great when when I
gonna love this and because I was just
constantly waiting for that feeling I
just never would listen to her and I
never really got into her but I've
always admired her because I know she
writes most of her songs maybe all but
at least most of her songs and uh I I
found this out after watching the error
stour that she actually directs most of
her music videos as well like she's a
true creative so I've always really
thought her work ethic is is amazing so
even if you like her music or not can't
deny her skill so the like a couple
weeks ago whenever this was announced um
I like surprised bought tickets for my
wife it was for Dolby Cinema and it was
uh so Dolby Cinema has like the best
projection and it has like the best
sound maybe not the biggest size like
IMAX but it's got those essential
ingredients when you're hearing like a
three-hour concert movie um but I still
hadn't listened to any Taylor so cut to
cut to like a couple weeks out Brian
tickets I'm at the gym I'm working out
I'm doing my thing and Spotify is doing
its Auto playlist thing of songs I've
ever heard and that's usually how I
discover new songs a song starts playing
and I I'm like halfway through and I'm
like oh I'm really loving this song so I
go to add it to my liked playl and then
lo and behold you guessed it it was a
Taylor Swift song and I had no idea I
was listening to Taylor Swift and I was
like oh what song was it U oh my God
hold on let me pull it right here it's
at the very very top it's from album
reputation it's so good it it's uh it's
not actually at the Eros tore it's I did
something bad is the name of the song so
I really loved it and I texted my wife
like you're not going to believe this
and so then I found on Spotify that they
have the whole I was like okay if I'm
gonna sit through three hours of this I
want to at least like know every song
because for me when I go to a concert I
tend to enjoy them better if I actually
know at least have some familiar some
familiarity with some of the songs and
so on the ays tour they have like the
entire playlist and so I was like I'm
just going to listen to all this for the
next few
days and then I was like all right I
think I'm starting to like Taylor Swift
I think I'm really think I'm really
coming around then I would find myself
going I really want to continue
listening then I'd be like working on
thumbnails and I'm listening to Taylor
sft I'm like I think I'm really getting
into Taylor Swift go to the theater and
um I did not know this until after this
is actually where the premiere or at the
screen where where she actually
premiered the movie I didn't even know
that um so I was like oh I had I had the
perfect choice so for you guys who don't
know why this concert is a is a big deal
she would usually do she's done a bunch
of albums and she would do like an album
and then do a tour with that album being
the title of that tour and there was
like a fewe period where she did like
Five albums but she wasn't touring she
wasn't doing these live performances
these concert shows so what she did was
this mega event the ays tour where she
just combined this like crazy thing
where she just just combined all five
albums into one mega concert
performance and I was still like you
know I like Taylor Swift but is this GNA
be am I gonna zone out am I gonna be
bored the thing's almost three hours
long am I gon to be bored watching this
and I had never even though I was listen
to all of it I had never actually even
seen a Taylor music video and I never
watched like some live performance video
from her before so this was my first
experience like watching her perform so
you didn't even know her before she was
cool I feel like I like ta us with more
than you Greg you listen to music
really we never go out style I love
style Banger Bad Blood Banger I knew you
were trouble when you walked in Banger
Banger oh my God yeah dude what was you
gotta go with your wife all right I I
say you remember me standing in a nice
dress looking at the dude I thought you
were gonna be bored here the you should
go watch this
because long the concert was there was
something really enchanting about it it
was like actually kind of magical
because there's nothing like it like I
took a little video of it and like
people from pretty much from beginning
to end were were dancing nonstop like
and there's you know how they have like
stadium seating and then like in front
of the screen people were like going
down there and they were taking turns
and just sort of dancing and it's it's
not it wasn't distracting it elevated
The Experience because a lot of people
can't go to a Taylor Swift concert and
this is their way of getting to
experience it because a big part of it
is the communal Joy of getting to have
this together and as someone who has
been to several concerts for stuff I
still would really love like even if I
had gone to the concert I'd still want
to go see it like my wife because at a
concert you're you're at one spot and
you don't get to get all these like
different Vantage points of views and
all these things that you would get
through all these iety of camera angles
and to be able to experience this in a
theater was something very very unique
and I feel like a lot of people are
after this there's going to be other
musicians other artists maybe other
bands who are going to be wanting to do
this as well because there's nothing
quite like it for a theater-going
experience that I found myself really
enjoying and in terms of like Taylor
Swift for her concert what was so cool
is she has such a vast variety of genre
vast variety of Music sounds and they
all ring authentic versus I never get
the impression she's an artist trying
something it just sound seems true to
her at that moment in time and there's a
lot of different costume changes a lot
of different variety of music and um she
her ability to connect with audience and
fans is like very very mesmerizing man
uh I I really loved it and and it's I
didn't think I was going to love it I I
thought like I would enjoy myself I but
I wasn't expecting to really love it and
it's something that I have thought about
repetitively throughout the day like
consistently since coming back from it
and then I find myself like watching
interviews with her and whatnot so I
think what she's done is something kind
of groundbreaking and is will will be
something other people are going to try
to emulate and she it's it's really
really really impressive I love I I I
really love my experience with her and I
think I hope more people get to
experience it it's not the kind of thing
you can just get from home and on top of
that the last thing I want to say yeah
the turnaround on this because the
concert was only a few months ago the
turnaround for the editing for this is
remarkable because you got to keep
people freaking engaged for a three hour
concert that it's not just a single shot
you know you're doing a variety of
angles of whatever you got to handle
your Transitions and the editing to get
this editing down on a turnaround for a
three-hour show where you're combining
two performances from LA and you got to
make it look like one Flawless they did
a Flawless job on it uh yeah I it was um
I've become a Swifty that's what
happened over the course of four weeks
Paul I'm now a
Swifty yeah well it sounds like you you
managed to do it and had the best time
of your life In Your Wildest streams a
lot of people would shake it off but all
you had to do was stay and it Rook you
out of the woods into a kind of a blank
space where you were clean and I Know
Places um where you can get this love
and it's sort of how you get the girl in
the end when you think about it really
God that's what I'd say and Shake It Off
shake it off and I'll Write Your Name
all you had to do was stay have you have
you heard the midnight album really her
latest album it's so good uh no yeah
yeah of course I have I don't know the
the thing is the way that I consume
music now I don't know any of the names
of stuff whereas when I used to buy
albums used to read the back and all
stuff whereas now I'll just be like put
on put on the album and they'll play it
and I'll be like no idea what this
song's called but I'll sing along to it
that's that's exactly what I that's why
I couldn't name it because I just let I
just let [__] play but I don't actually
know what the title of the songs are all
the time so I would find myself like
singing along but I'm like I don't know
what the song's
called yeah well uh I'm sure we've still
got people listening right now so if you
are please don't don't leave us hit the
hit the Thumbs Up Button hit the
Subscribe check us out on Amazon podcast
check us out on Spotify podcast check us
out wherever I'm absolutely over the
moon Greg I've just had two big
screeners hit the inbox we've got the
genv finale we've got Invincible who it
up in the city so very excited to see
that while you were talk while you were
talking about Taylor Swift I was sitting
going yes pretend I'm listening when I'm
trying to focus on this that's usually
what you do already when I'm talking
generally about any topic you're just
like when do we segue to the next I'm
kind of flicking between 20 different
tabs all at once to see what big stories
are so yeah please Hollywood don't drop
any big Bombshells on us tomorrow when
this podcast releases but yeah thanks
for listening to it guys we love you for
all your support and it really means a
lot and uh yeah thanks a lot than you
guys any final way no thank you guys for
listening really enjoy my time here and
appreciate you guys support share the
podcast share it share it I feel like
we're getting better and better all the
time share it sort sort of